Queridos amigos, amigas, cada dos por tres
nos encontramos con titulares y noticias como
estos:
N1 (17 de marzo del 2023.
Rusia: La Corte Penal Internacional emite
una orden de arresto contra Putin.
ONU)
N2 (28 de junio de 2023: La CPI reanudará
las investigaciones de presuntos crímenes
de lesa humanidad en Venezuela.
France 24)
N3 (7 de julio de 2023: El fiscal de la CPI
busca acelerar la investigación contra Birmania
por los rohinyás.
InfoBae)
Y la pregunta es, ¿sirven de algo los tribunales
internacionales?
¿Han dado algún resultado hasta la fecha?
¿Realmente puede Vladímir Putin terminar
tras las rejas por una sentencia emitida en
la Haya?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas.
Pero lo primero, lo primero es saber dónde
y como empezó todo este temas de los tribunales
internacionales.
Toca ver un poco de historia.
[Pero, antes solo un segundo.
¿Quieres estar al tanto de los principales
acontecimientos que influyen en los mercados?
¿Quieres saber más sobre posibles crisis
o sobre el estado de las principales economías
del mundo?
Pues no te pierdas Si lo Hubiera Sabido, en
canal de información de Mutuactivos con el
que participamos.
Por ejemplo, ¿Sabías que corremos el riesgo
de sufrir una gran crisis del cobre?
¿Cómo Japón está escapando de su larga
crisis?
o, hablando de Rusia, ¿Cómo Putin está
logrando saltarse las sanciones internacionales?
Pues todo esto y más lo encontrarás en Si
lo Hubiera Sabido.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Y ahora sí, arranquemos.]
T1 (LOS PRIMEROS ANTECEDENTES)
La guerra de Ucrania ha sido uno de los últimos
casos que han hecho que la justicia internacional
se ponga las pilas.
A comienzos del mes de julio de 2023 se puso
en marcha formalmente esta nueva iniciativa:
N4 (3 de julio de 2023: La Haya: abre un centro
para investigar la guerra de Rusia en Ucrania.
La UE dijo que el centro tiene el "objetivo
final de enjuiciar a los responsables de la
invasión" de Ucrania..
DW)
El Centro Internacional para el Enjuiciamiento
del Crimen de Agresión incluye fiscales de
Ucrania, la Unión Europea, Estados Unidos
y la Corte Penal Internacional (CPI).
La idea es que este centro recopile pruebas
y prepare cargos contra los funcionarios del
Kremlin.
C1 (“No dejaremos piedra sin remover para
que Putin y sus secuaces rindan cuentas”.
Ursula von der Leyen.)
Ahora bien, quizás penséis que toda esta
historia de la justicia internacional es algo
bastante nuevo, pero lo cierto es que no es
así.
Irónicamente, fue la propia Rusia la que
comenzó a pensar en iniciativas de este tipo
hace ya más de 100 años.
En 1899, en la propia ciudad de La Haya, el
zar Nicolás II hizo una convocatoria global
para desarrollar una “Conferencia de Paz”
con el fin de establecer una modalidad de
arbitraje internacional que fuera capaz de
buscar soluciones pacíficas a todos aquellos
problemas que podrían terminar desencadenando
una guerra.
Esto llevo a la creación de la Corte Permanente
de Arbitraje en la Haya.
Y vale, ya sé lo que algunos estaríais pEensando.
Pero, Alberto, menuda birria.
¿Cómo que una corte de arbitraje si apenas
unos pocos años después estalló la Primera
Guerra Mundial y poco después la Segunda?
¡Vaya fracaso!
Pues…
Sí, en cierto modo, tenéis toda la razón.
A la hora de evitar guerras no fue particularmente
útil.
Al final, esta Corte de arbitraje básicamente
se ciñó a resolver disputas entre diferentes
países sobre los límites marítimos o la
soberanía de islas.
Por lo general, asuntos relativamente menores,
entre otras cosas porque para que se cumplieran
sus disposiciones los países afectados tenían
que hacerlo voluntariamente.
Al fin y al cabo no existe una policía mundial
que obligue a los países a cumplir las sentencias
de este organismo.
Incluso si un país se negaba a participar
en el proceso, pues colorín colorado, el
cuento se había acabado.
Ahora bien, ¿quiere decir todo esto que la
justicia internacional no vale para nada?
Pues… ojo, porque los 100 años que han
pasado desde la conferencia de paz promovida
por el zar Nicolás II no h an transcurrido
en vano.
Es posible que hoy, Vladímir Putin, tenga
algún motivo de más del que preocuparse.
:)
Pero, no nos adelantemos.
Amigos y amigas, la Primera Guerra Mundial
trajo consigo un nivel de destrucción que
hasta entonces parecía impensable.
Quizás por eso que, por primera vez en toda
la historia, en el Tratado de Versalles (1919)
se establecieron tres artículos que abrieron
por primera vez la posibilidad de juzgar a
los Estados agresores.
Concretamente, fueron los artículos 227,
229 y 230.
Claro que al final quedaron en nada.
Hubo algunos juicios, pero no condenas.
Los aliados optaron por intentar superar lo
antes posible las tensiones con Alemania.
Así que, no, no hubo responsables condenados
por la Primera Guerra Mundial o los crímenes
de guerra cometidos durante la contienda.
(Pese a ello, las tensiones no desaparecieron
y poco después llego el nazismo y la Segunda
Guerra Mundial.
Y ahí ya si todo fue diferente.
Los crímenes nazis fueron tan absolutamente
atroces que en 1945 se firmó el Estatuto
de Londres del Tribunal Militar Internacional,
donde los aliados acordaron los principios
y los procedimientos que regirían lo que
más tarde conocimos como Juicios de Núremberg.)
Pero no vayamos tan rápido porque luego llegó
la Guerra Fría.
Y claro, es que acaso ¿Iba a estar un tribunal
internacional investigando las acciones represivas
de la Stasi en Alemania oriental, la intervención
soviética en Praga, o la intervención norteamericana
en Vietnam?
Evidentemente no.
Y de haberlo intentado, eso podría haber
terminado con la Tercera Guerra Mundial.
Así que lo que se hizo fue algo diferente.
Por un lado, en 1945 se creó la Corte Internacional
de Justicia para dirimir disputas legales
entre Estados, y que en cierto modo mantenía
la naturaleza del arbitraje, lo que ya suponía
una enorme limitación.
Y es que veréis, esta corte internacional
necesitaba que cuando se diera un problema,
las partes implicadas aceptaran acudir y respetar
la jurisdicción de este organismo.
Y claro, el problem a estaba servido.
Pensadlo bien, ¿acaso un ladrón de bancos
va a aceptar de buena fe ser juzgado y acatar
libremente la sentencia?
Evidentemente no.
Pues con los Estados pasa tres cuartas partes
de lo mismo.
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo, por otro lado,
la ONU acordó que fuese en todo caso el Consejo
de Seguridad el organismo que tuviera la potestad
de deliberar y hacer cumplir las resoluciones
de este organismo en casos particularmente
graves.
Y como en ese organismo tanto Estados Unidos
como la Unión Soviética tenían derecho
de veto…
Pues… digamos que en la práctica todo esto
de la Justicia Internacional solo afectaba
a cuestiones menores.
Y así fue hasta que se produjo una nueva
guerra en Europa.
Para ello tenemos que dar un salto de casi
50 años.
Estamos hablando por supuesto de la guerra
en la antigua Yugoslavia.
Una guerra donde serbios, bosnios y croatas
se encontraban en una lucha sin cuartel en
la que abundaban las denuncias sobre todo
tipo de crímenes.
La situación se puso tan fea que en 1993
el Consejo de Seguridad decidió crear el
Tribunal Penal Internacional para la antigua
Yugoslavia para perseguir precisamente los
crímenes de lesa humanidad.
Además, poco después, en abril de 1994,
estalló en Ruanda uno de los conflictos étnicos
más sangrientos de la historia moderna.
El gobierno hutu asesinó sistemáticamente
al 70% de la población tutsi.
Hablamos de cientos de miles de víctimas.
Y al igual que en el caso de bosnia, aquí
también se creó un Tribunal Penal Internacional
para Ruanda.
(Al final, en el caso de Bosnia se enjuiciaron
a 90 altos funcionarios civiles y militares.
Mientras que en el caso de Ruanda fueron 61
personas las procesadas.
El coronel ruandés, Théoneste Bagosora y
el primer ministro del país durante la masacre,
Jean Kambanda, terminaron tras las rejas.
El presidente yugoslavo Slobodan Milošević
y el líder serbio, Radovan Karadžić, corrieron
también la misma suerte.)
Y sí, durante el proceso estos organismos
tuvieron muchas limitaciones.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de Bosnia, el conflicto
no solo continuó tras ponerse en marcha el
Tribunal Penal Internacional para la antigua
Yugoslavia, sino que dos años más tarde
se registró la masacre de [SRE-BRE-NI-CHÁ]
Srebrenica: 8.000 bosnios musulmanes resultaron
asesinados, en una acción realizada por fuerzas
aliadas de Serbia.
Pero, sea como sea, en última instancia,
una cosa quedó meridianamente clara: si realmente
se quería disuadir y castigar crímenes,
había que superar todo ese tema del arbitraje
y hacía falta un organismo que fuera permanente
y no temporal como los Tribunales especiales
para Ruanda y Bosnia.
La justicia internacional necesitaba una auténtica
Corte que fuese capaz de llevar a cabo investigaciones
y procesos de forma unilateral y cuyas sentencias
fuesen vinculantes.
Pues bien, para lograrlo en 1998, a instancias
de Naciones Unidas, se aprobó el conocido
como Estatuto de Roma, a partir del cual en
el año 2002 comenzó a funcionar la Corte
Penal Internacional.
Un organismo que nació con una operativa
completamente diferente.
Aunque el Consejo de Seguridad o la Asamblea
de la ONU puedan enviar casos a la corte,
la fiscalía de este organismo por sí misma
puede iniciar automáticamente y de forma
unilateral sus propias investigaciones.
Es decir, ya no tenía que contar con la aprobación
de nadie, ni de las partes implicadas, ni
de las grandes potencias, ni del Consejo de
Seguridad.
Teóricamente, el salto era galáctico.
Ahora bien, ¿Podrá este organismo procesar
a los jerarcas rusos?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (CAMINO SIN SALIDA)
Todo esto de la Justicia Internacional puede
sonar muy bien, pero, ¿sabéis qué?
A la hora de la verdad, a muy pocos gobiernos
les gusta eso de que un organismo internacional
ande por ahí husmeando en sus asuntos.
Y desde luego las grandes potencias son un
buen ejemplo.
Y eso es exactamente lo que explica noticias
como estas:
N5 (22 de mayo del 2014: Rusia y China vetan
la medida de la ONU para llevar a Siria a
la corte penal internacional.
The Guardian)
N6 (14 de junio de 2020: Trump autoriza sanciones
contra funcionarios de la Corte Penal Internacional.
La última medida se produce meses después
de que la CPI autorizara una investigación
sobre presuntos crímenes de guerra cometidos
en Afganistán por las fuerzas estadounidenses
y afganas.
CNN)
De hecho, aunque en 1998 la Administración
de Bill Clinton fue muy activa a la hora de
promover el Estatuto de Roma, cuando llegó
la hora de ratificarlo, la Administración
Bush decidió no hacerlo.
¿Los motivos?
El presidente norteamericano lo dejó muy
claro.
C2 (“Ustedes saben que mientras Estados
Unidos trabaja para llevar la paz a todo el
mundo, nuestros diplomáticos y soldados podrían
ser llevados a este tribunal y eso es muy
preocupante para mí”.
George W.
Bush)
Y, por supuesto, no solo fue Estados Unidos.
Países como China, Rusia, India, Israel o
Turquía, entre muchos más casos, tampoco
lo han firmado o ratificado.
De hecho, hoy por hoy el Estatuto de Roma
solo está en vigor en los países pintados
de verde.
Es decir, que la Corte Penal Internacional
existe, pero hoy por hoy ninguna gran potencia
reconoce su jurisdicción.
Potencias que también pueden impedir con
su veto que el Consejo de Seguridad le pida
a la Corte investigar casos concretos…
Que es la opción que existe para llevar a
cabo procesos en países que no han ratificado
el Tratado de Roma.
Esto es así porque supuestamente los países
miembros de la ONU están obligados a cumplir
con las resoluciones del Consejo de Seguridad.
Pese a todo, la corte funciona.
(Actualmente, la Corte Penal Internacional
tiene en marcha 17 investigaciones, entre
las que destacan la persecución de crímenes
de guerra en la República Democrática del
Congo, Uganda, Libia y Sudan, así como delitos
de lesa humanidad en Afganistán, Palestina
y Venezuela.
En varios de estos casos esta corte ha llegado
a emitir órdenes de arresto.)
Amigos, la madre patria Rusia se enfrenta
a la Corte Penal Internacional no solo en
el caso de Ucrania, sino también en lo que
respecta a los supuestos crímenes cometidos
durante su intervención militar en Georgia
en el año 2008.
Y la pregunta, la gran pregunta es: ¿hasta
qué punto tienen que preocuparle a Putin
lo que ocurra en la Haya?
Pues…
Atentos.
T3 (¿EL VIAJE A KIEV TERMINA EN LA HAYA?)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik la invasión
a Ucrania tiene dos procesos judiciales internacionales
abiertos:
Uno en la Corte Internacional de Justicia
ante la cual Ucrania denunció a la Federación
Rusa el 26 de febrero de 2022, pidiendo amparar
a los ciudadanos ucranianos de un posible
genocidio.
El 16 de marzo de 2022 esta Corte dictaminó
que Rusia debía “suspender inmediatamente
las operaciones militares”.
Rusia, por supuesto, hizo caso omiso.
Así que nada que hacer por esa vía.
Por otra parte, la Corte Penal internacional
recibió la segunda denuncia, aunque esta
no provino directamente del gobierno de Volodímir
Zelenski.
La primera semana de marzo de 2022, el fiscal
de la Corte Penal Internacional, Karim Khan,
recibió múltiples peticiones de los gobiernos
de Lituania, Albania, Australia, Austria,
Colombia, Costa Rica y Finlandia, entre otros
países, para iniciar una investigación sobre
lo que estaba aconteciendo en Ucrania.
Esta investigación, sin embargo, está resultando
muy particular.
Además de poner el foco en Putin, también
se investiga el rol de María Alekseyevna
Lvova-Belova, Comisionada para los Derechos
del Niño en la Oficina del presidente de
la Federación Rusa.
Se les acusa a ambos de ser los autores intelectuales
de la “deportación ilegal de niños desde
las zonas ocupadas de Ucrania a la Federación
Rusa”,
N7 (3 de julio de 2023: Moscú dice que 700.000
niños de las zonas de conflicto de Ucrania
ahora están en Rusia.
Reuters)
Pero, ¿Por qué se está investigando a Rusia
si este país no ha ratificado el Estatuto
de Roma?
Pues porque aunque Rusia no lo hizo, Ucrania
que es el país perjudicado, aunque todavía
no lo ha ratificado, sí que lo firmó, además,
aceptó explícitamente la jurisdicción de
este organismo en relación con los crímenes
cometidos en su territorio desde 2014.
. Y eso permite que las investigaciones puedan
continuar.
Y es lo que explica la noticia que veíamos
al principio de este vídeo.
Esta:
N8 (17 de marzo del 2023.
Rusia: La Corte Penal Internacional emite
una orden de arresto contra Putin.
ONU)
Ahora bien, ¿puede prosperar esta acusación?
Pues…
Por ahora las posibilidades parecen pocas.
Rusia no reconoce la jurisdicción de la Corte
Penal Internacional y este organismo no tiene
la capacidad de hacer cumplir sus disposiciones.
En general, hasta ahora las grandes potencias
han sido totalmente indiferentes a todos estos
tribunales internacionales sin tener que asumir
ningún coste:
Podemos hablar de las acusaciones contra Estados
Unidos por su intervención en Afganistán
o en Irak, de la toma china de Hong Kong o
ahora de la Guerra de Ucrania.
Y claro, sin el apoyo de Estados Unidos…
Ya os imaginaréis que las capacidades reales
de este organismo son muy limitados.
Pese a ello, en el caso de Putin, los tribunales
internacionales ya están recabando activamente
pruebas sobre la violación de derechos humanos
en Ucrania.
Digamos que en algún lugar de los Países
Bajos hay un gabinete lleno de documentos
que podrían complicar la impunidad de la
camarilla que hoy maneja el Kremlin,
Si mañana cambiase el liderazgo en Rusia…
Putin podría verse en una situación muy
comprometida, porque básicamente no tendría
tan fácil encontrar refugio, entre otras
cosas porque tendrá órdenes internacionales
de arresto cursadas en su contra.
Nada es imposible…
Pero, Milošević y Bagosora actuaron con
la misma impunidad en su momento y al final
terminaron entre rejas.
Pero por ahora no parece que eso sea particularmente
probable.
En cualquier caso, llegados hasta aquí, nos
asalta una última pregunta: ¿Realmente sirve
para algo la Corte Penal Internacional?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que aunque no esté siendo el
organismo más importante del mundo, sí que
está sirviendo para dos cosas:
Primero para perseguir a ciertos dictadorzuelos
particularmente sangrientos.
Aunque actualmente la Corte solo mantiene
a 7 personas bajo custodia con juicios en
marcha, entre ellos se encuentran Ali Muhammad
Ali Abd-Al-Rahman, jefe de milicias armadas
sudanesas, acusado de perpetrar 31 crímenes
de guerra en el conflicto armado que atañe
a dicho país; o Bosco Ntaganda, líder guerrillero
congolés, también con una docena crímenes
de guerra encima.
Eso es mejor que nada.
Por otra parte, la Corte ha contribuido a
denunciar los comportamientos excesivos de
ciertos gobiernos.
El caso de Putin es un buen ejemplo, pero
también lo es este otro:
N9 (La Corte Penal Internacional investigará
a Venezuela por crímenes de lesa humanidad
La Fiscalía de La Haya dirimirá ejecuciones
extrajudiciales, detenciones arbitrarias y
torturas cometidas bajo el Gobierno de Maduro.
El País)
N10 (Corte Penal Internacional recibe más
de 2.000 testimonios de víctimas sobre investigación
por crímenes de lesa humanidad [En Venezuela].
PROVEA)
Pero llegados hasta aquí, el turno es para
ti:
¿Qué te parece la existencia de tribunales
de justicia internacionales?
¿Crees que deberían reforzarse?
¿Terminará Putin procesado y entre rejas?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí, un saludo y
hasta la próxima.